Jada Pinkett Smith has always worn her
heart on her sleeve and now that's true
more than ever everybody's invited on
Sunday the red table talk host took to
Instagram to show off her new tattoo and
as Jada teased in the caption she's just
getting started I think there might be
some things in the Horizon Jada
explained I always said I would get a
sleeve at 60 but tomorrow is not
promised so I'm starting to build my
sleeve now her large arm tattoo has
references to goddesses from several
different religions and the spiritual
tribute Follows daughter Willow Smith's
recent ink like you're loved this is a
safe space last month the 20 year old
singer got this large hand tattoo of the
Hindu goddess Saraswati well how could I
miss the opportunity like that this also
comes after the red table talk ladies
got matching Lotus tattoos which they
discussed on their Facebook Watch series
earlier this year and we hear this
saying like through the mud grows the
Lotus right and that's definitely my
story yes 100 and I think all of us from
different perspectives in life have had
that Journey the bud to the little
blossom to the bloom also I feel like
expresses the spiritual journey but also
the three of us I'm the youngest you
know my mom is the middle and gam is the
the fully bloomed Lotus willow also
revealed she was nervous to tell Dad
Will Smith about her half sleeve since
will doesn't have any tattoos himself
like I showed my mom the the art for my
half sleeve like I want to say like
three weeks before I got it
and but I didn't tell my dad I showed it
to him and he was like everything is in
divine order your path is your path and
I just love you yeah and I'm glad that
you got something that actually looks
nice the multi-generational hosts opened
up to E.T about what makes their
Dynamics special earlier this year I'm
telling you I mean people I would never
even think or watching red table talk
from 60 year old white men to like you
know 16 year old boys you know what I
mean it's just so beautiful that we've
been able to connect with such a variety
you know so many groups of of people
from different generations and from
different countries and you know from
different economic backgrounds you know
on a common ground all on a common
ground of just
trying to figure out how to live a happy
authentic life right I wanted a
community so that when the conversation
was over when we were done that there
were people that could still gather yes
talk and commune about whatever people
together together so there's been like
different red table talk communities all
over Facebook that have popped up you
know what I mean and so that's also been
a really deep blessing and treasure
[Music]